the other bizarre item that I want to
talk about here is George Santos again
sat down with aoan in a wide-ranging
interview very candid exclusive
interview with One America news and
he's not backing down
he apologizes out of one side of his
mouth and then says that uh he's a lot
of people are creating a fake narrative
that he faked his way to Congress or a
narrative that he faked his way there
ignoring all of the lies and he's taking
issue with it he's acting like it's
unfair how he's being treated
differently than any other member of
Congress and then finally a clip that
he's going to go ahead and extra step
now and double check and cross-reference
everything as though he needs to do that
with the details of his own life it's
all a bit much watch this first clip the
business of politics is littered at the
highest levels with
see Miss true Corruption of course and
this is kind of the time that you're now
entering politics so with that climate
in mind
um
I guess where do you want to start and
your is your story your upbringing Maybe
well Caitlin look I come from a humble
beginning I've always said that I grew
up in abject poverty uh in Jackson
Heights in Queens in New York City uh
people like me aren't supposed to do big
things in life and when we do it
disrupts the system and I know that a
lot of people want to create this
narrative that I I faked my way to
Congress which is absolutely
categorically false I've worked hard
I've built ground up a career
um through experience and through
knowledge and through self-education and
you know I think it's amazing that I
have to sit here and be spoken down to
on a regular basis yet again by the
media
is George Santos really does he have the
gall and the temerity and the the
boldness to to try to play this off as
the system coming down on him because
he's the poor lowly poor kid who isn't
supposed to make it
that the all the odds were stacked
against me
growing up poor in abject poverty
doesn't mean that you makes you a liar
take it from me I grew up exceedingly
poor on welfare free lunch all the works
the food stamps
it doesn't make you a liar
and here watch this Mr I've I've made
atonements I've made apologies I'm very
sorry I shouldn't have done what I did
here he is whining about the unfair
treatment that he's undergoing right now
now Angry
that's maybe you can say that I'm
passionate about all of this but anger
is just not something you I would think
is appropriate to describe me what
emotions do you feel right now you know
sad
sad that I've I put myself in this
predicament and and and I own up to it
but
I'm sad that the media has decided now
to Target my family
the media has decided to Target and
harass my friends anybody around me I
signed up for this job Caitlyn I signed
up for this not my my sister with my
five-year-old autistic niece or not my
husband at home with our dogs they
didn't sign up but you knew you knew
putting yourself and anyone that puts
themselves in the spotlight they know
what baggage that comes with
I have yet to see this be done to other
members of congress's family from the
death threats to the media harassment
pounding down the door leaving passive
aggressive notes all things I'd be glad
to share with you and if you can air the
stern this I'll share you passive
aggressive threatening notes
a threatening note is not passive
aggressive
it's aggressive it's threatening it's
also a crime
so if you have evidence of journalists
threatening you
I go to the thought of authorities
that there it is a federal crime
to threaten the life or threaten a
sitting member of Congress
do the good hard work George Santos
the media is not targeting you and
you're not being unfairly treated you
think you're the only member of I don't
believe you're getting death threats but
do you think you're the only member of
Have you listened to to Eric swalwell
and the voicemails he releases on his
Twitter
Cry Me a River you've created the media
frenzy you should be pleased as punch at
what has taken place
so enough
we get it
follow me on social media if you'd like
to leave me threatening and uh passive
aggressive notes I'm at dollamore on
Twitter Instagram and Tick Tock you can
find me here on YouTube uh dollar more
daily is the show that I host Daily
Dollar more see how it works
I also co-host a podcast with Brittany
page called I doubt it that you can find
at dollarmore.com or anywhere that you
find podcasts I'd love to see you there
it's a new year many of us are trying to
make new positive changes here's
something really simple that could be a
game changer our sponsor athletic greens
every day I take a scoop of ag1 I get 75
high quality vitamins minerals and Whole
Food sourced ingredients to last me all
day long this way I just know my
nutritional bases are covered for the
entire day it has everything I want and
that's important to me rather than doing
the individual supplements and vitamins
or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below